and meanwhile a radical group of 2020
Democrats they're getting a free pass
from virtually everyone in the media mob
that includes sleepy creepy crazy uncle
Joe he's supposed to be the experienced
competent frontrunner in a crowded field
of candidates in reality he is a walking
disaster and by now we all know that the
obama-biden record that was a complete
and utter failure we also know that Joe
303 300 which meant nothing
he's a non-stop human gaffe machine but
Biden's problems they actually go much
deeper recently the Washington Examiner
compiling a list of the six times Biden
described major events in his life that
never happened including a wild story
about his helicopter getting forced down
near Osama bin Laden's hideout in
Afghanistan he also once falsely claimed
that the that he worked as a coal miner
and that he was shot in at in Iraq
according to the 2010 book Game Change
President Obama openly wondered quote
how many times does Biden gonna say
something stupid a creepy crazy Uncle
Joe reportedly told Obama that he would
never have to worry about his own
presidential ambitions because he was
quote too old but fear not
Biden's brain surgeon is here to
reassure the American people thirty
years ago he performed surgery on
then-senator Biden following two brain
aneurysms but today he told the Politico
that he is quote absolutely certain that
he has a brain that is functioning brain
that is functioning okay
good news now Biden also received
another glowing endorsement from his own
wife well she told voters to hold their
nose swallow a little and judge Janine
Lavin and make these sensible choice
hold your nose vote for my husband is
that like a new campaign thing anyway
look for yourself you know your
candidate might be better off I don't
know health care then Joe is
but you've got a look at who's gonna win
this election and maybe you have to
swallow a little bit and say okay I sort
of personally like soso better hold your
nose and swallow Wow
with enthusiasm like that from his own
wife
I'm sure Biden has this nomination this
sucker locked right down